hey guys and welcome to episode number
nine of my GE only challenge uh last
episode I did end up making a few
different goals uh the first one is uh
we got two 60 wood cutting so we can now
cut U trees and go in the area uh we
also uh manag to unlock our
p uh so we can now start really training
our construction up and now with the
next goal is going to be shooting for
750 total level I'm getting pretty close
uh with construction and and leveling up
my smithing and maybe uh my uh prayer a
little bit uh we should be able to hit
it relatively soon maybe this episode
maybe not we'll have to see and our cash
dech is a bit low but I'm going to try
to figure out some other methods uh that
don't take a lot to begin with to start
growing our cash up more so we can start
investing in uh spending more money on
Skilling like actual good methods for
like crafting stuff like that and
eventually unlocking her blor so thanks
a lot for watching and let's get started
okay we have another Oak tree coming
through I think just our second oak tree
let's see how much experience we get
it's going to be 467 and one farming
level great I think I might consider
buying some more of the bagged tree
plants to get to well 27 farming so I
can make the uh willow tree uh just cuz
I think it's going to help speed things
up a lot okay we're back at the
construction grind still making these
bookcases uh reasonably quick there is
level 30 construction uh we just need to
get to 33 and then I can continue to or
start to make Oak lers uh which is kind
of one of the best methods for a long
time uh it should be at least 80k an
hour there we go there's level 33
construction that is going to let us
build Oak lers and I'll have to go ahead
and purchase a bunch of oak logs and
this is going to start getting pretty
pricey but I want to get a 50
construction roughly okay so we built
the room that has a Larder in it is
right by the portal unfortunately have
to go into building mode each time which
is really annoying but you get 480
experience per Larter you can only do
three per inventory then have to
teleport back to the Grand exchange but
still XP wise definitely a lot better
okay we have a couple more trees coming
through this one's going to get us to
level 18 farming I'm still getting about
one level uh per tree but one thing I
just thought of is you should be able to
chop the tree and chop it like a regular
tree like it should respawn relatively
quickly uh so by getting the maple trees
or even willow trees I should be able to
get better wooden experience than what
was originally available so that's
really exciting I never even thought
about that uh planting maple trees even
magic trees okay we're back to making
the largers and that is going to be
level 40 construction just from the
largers going pretty quickly but is
costing a lot I'm not sure how many more
levels I'm going to go because I don't
really have a lot of money to dump in
here right now but I would like to get
55 for the armor repair stand cuz that
would help me with the money-making
method but don't think I have enough for
now all right here's another farming
level coming in that's going to be 19
farming not too exciting but one thing
that is exciting is if I do get the
Willow in maple trees it does look like
I should be able to get higher
experience rates than from the oak trees
that I have right now okay we're just
double checking this here so we're going
to cut down the oak tree as long as you
don't remove the stump of the tree I
believe uh it should respa in just 5
Seconds roughly or the same length as a
regular tree uh cuz willow trees we're
getting about 30 to 35k experience
cutting oak trees so willow trees would
hopefully be better and Maples would be
even better but I think this episode I
should be able to go get my farming to
27 or 30 whatever just to get a willow
tree then I can actually test it for
myself okay so the stump's gone and it's
only been about 3 seconds 4 seconds 5
seconds is it going to come back okay
there we go yeah pretty much like a
regular tree awesome okay we just have
another Fletching level coming in there
is going to be level 76 fling I kind of
feeling like this is going to be my
first 99 because really good experience
raids and it doesn't cost anything to
train it you're actually making money
the whole time pretty well uh so yeah
we're going to continue making these you
long bows and I still have some Maples
in the bank so I thought I would go
ahead and just start burning them uh
really easy experience I could still
burn mahogany logs or te logs but I
don't know I just want it to cost
virtually nothing so it's still pretty
good experience 140k an hour there is
level 57 fir making I'll see if I can
get 60 right now okay we got another fir
making level coming in uh starting to
get a little bored of this now but still
was able to get about 130k consistently
per hour that is going to be level 60
fir making there we go uh we canot burn
you logs if we actually want to but I
don't know if that's going to happen all
right so we'll just put hit another
farming level it's going to be level 21
now I've kind of decided I'm going to
use the bag Plants because doing this by
hand is going to take 20 saplings 20 or
30 which is going to take like a week
and a half I'd rather just spend 200k
and get my farming to 30 and then just
really help speed up that process okay
so what web is baged dead trees now I
mistakenly put in this amount I actually
need less because I'm only going to go
to 27 and do a plus re Boost from there
but anyway we'll start putting the
offers in they're going to come in
really slowly but we'll leave it in for
a day or two okay there's another
Fletching level there's 77 Fletching
still just slowly working our way up
it's just it's kind of the only activity
I have right now that doesn't cost money
to train experience then that's kind of
why I'm looking forward to unlocking MOS
Giants going down to the sewer and just
training my combat skills up while I
wait for flips to come
in okay so we have a quick uh flip
coming in for Holy wraps only about
25k in each one so 75k in total profit
there not amazing but it is kind of nice
to have our money doing something
otherwise just sitting around okay so we
have managed to buy some of the bagged
dead trees very slow to come in but we
actually managed to buy like 50 at once
for some reason um but I'm not
questioning it we need another 120 or
something to get to 27 farming but we'll
do these for now all right really nice
and easy method you just build it and
then you remove it uh getting a decent
amount of experience each time there's
level 23 farming only four more levels
and then we can get the uh willow tree
planted okay we're just about to hit a
Construction level and this is uh quite
a while ways uh in the future from the
last clip uh so we have managed to buy
enough of the bag dead trees to get to
27 farming I didn't actually record that
part of the clip but they did come
through okay and here we are guys this
is the last inventory and this should be
27 farming that's a little tedious now
at this point but that's all we kind of
want for now we can do a plus three
boost and plant a willow tree and then
we can actually train our wood cutting a
little more efficiently as well okay so
we're going to plant our first willow
tree we need to Garden pie to plant it
uh the saplings are more expensive
they're like 8K each so it's going to
get a little pricey but since I only
have one patch it's really not going to
be that big a deal but there we go the
first bullet tree has been planted okay
we have a couple flips coming in and
also one extra moneymaking method I'm
going to be trying uh which is a super
compost method using compost potions uh
now some of you guys may remember this
from my channel 5 months ago but anyway
what you do is you're buying the compost
potions off of the grand exchange right
now they're really cheap I'm buying them
for 301 each and uh you're combining
them into Super compost potions or super
composts by using the potion on a
regular compost on each potion right now
I'm going to be profiting about 1,500 GP
uh and it's kind of slow to do but it's
not too bad uh so on every 100 compost
potions I do want to make 150k and that
takes about 10 minutes probably to do
that so it's pretty good for not having
any requirements and you don't even need
any money to start doing it either okay
there we go our first willow tree is
grown let's go check its health and see
how much experience we get it's going to
be 1,500 experience pretty well it's
pretty nice and there is level 28
farming I don't think I'm going to start
chopping it down yet because I do want
to do a couple other things first uh but
yeah later on we'll train our wood
cutting on this sick sick willry okay so
we combined all of the uh compost
potions into Super compost and we're
selling them off for
uh 200k and we only spent like 40K on
the ingredients I think so that's 160k
in profit and it only took me about 10
minutes to combine all the potions okay
we have quite a few things in the gr
change right now uh the sadom and chaps
is one item we're flipping for 20K
profit on each one which is pretty good
for how quickly they're coming through
and we flipped four of them so that's
80k in profit uh it's pretty good also
we have more compost potions coming
through they have a bind limit of 50 so
takes a while to buy them and we're also
flipping super compost at the same time
uh just because the margin is actually
really good on super compost uh but
again super compost has a pretty low
limit of 600 uh so that's not an ideal
flip but still our gr exchange is active
we got stuff going on okay so we have
another Willow Tree coming in and that
is going to bring us to 29 farming and I
think now I'm going to take the
opportunity to get one more wood cutting
level cuz right now I'm only at 60 wood
cutting and one more level I can use the
dragon axe so we'll go ahead and check
how good the willow tree is okay so
we're just about to hit the wood cutting
level and after all is said and done uh
we're getting about 40K wood cutting
experience an hour which is definitely
better surprisingly I come over here and
chop down the regular tree occasionally
but uh it's actually a lot better now
that we can use the dragon ax H will be
even more efficient so I'm pretty
excited actually came to this
realization okay so I'm just going to go
ahead and sell everything off in the gr
exchain and see how much money I have to
work with here uh the next thing I want
to do is level up my smithing by using
the super he spell it's only at like 20
right now or 25 uh so by leveling up
I'll get a lot of easy total levels okay
so we bought 1,000 iron ore and 1,000
nature runes I think Super Heen iron is
going to be the best at this level but
we can switch over to Steel later on if
we want to now I'm pretty sure these
1,000 cast should get me roughly to
level 30 smithing which we'll see if I
want to go anything past that cuz it's
pretty click intensive not terribly
interesting and it does cost a good
amount of money to do this but let's go
and give it a try and see what the XP
rates are like for magic and smithing
okay there's level 28 or 23 smithing
sorry and we also just recently got a
magic level uh it turns out it's about
80k an hour magic experience but I did
not know was that good only about
20K less than that probably smithing
experience so that's pretty slow but uh
getting both uh levels are pretty
consistently there we go there's level
25 smithing that's pretty good uh I
think I'll be able to get to 30 right
now and then I'll probably have to take
a break because it's pretty boring doing
all this clicking you can't even spam
click at all because you have to move
your cursor down okay we're just about
to hit a smithing level from Super
heating iron bars that is going to be
level 29 smithing uh as well as we're
going to hit a magic level kind of why I
recorded when two levels happen at the
exact same time uh it's something
special to celebrate so let's go ahead
and get level 53 magic as well there's
Earth blast if it ever comes in handy I
doubt it but there we go okay we're just
about to hit Level 30 Smith
which will allow us to make steel bars
out of coal and iron so we'll go give
that a shot I think the GP per XP is
cheaper for that uh but I'm not sure if
it's going to be easier just because you
have to combine the two we'll have to
give it a shot though okay so we have
500 iron ore 1,000 coal and 500 nature
runes so I'm going to give a 500 cast a
try uh and I guess I'll have to
withdraw nine iron and 18 coal which is
going to be kind of awkward so I tried
doing it but honestly it was really
awkward to do uh cuz you had to withdraw
the perfect amount of iron and coal and
the XP rates were actually the same if
not lower with a lot more clicking uh
required but anyway we're going to
continue on with the iron and there's
level 55 magic okay and we have one more
uh smithing level going to come in and I
think that'll be good for now there's 35
smithing and I think I'll have to take a
break so unfortunately the uh super the
uh steel bars didn't work out mainly
because of how click intensive it was
and the XP raats were kind of
anyway so we're going to continue on
with the iron and Future Okay and we're
just about to hit one more farming level
that is going to be level 30 farming
just from willow trees and uh I really
wanted to get to 750 total level for you
guys today but
unfortunately uh something came up H
which is going to kind of restrict me
from finishing any other goals for the
next day or two so I think I'm just
going to end it here and just upload
this for you guys I mean it's still
going to be 11 12 minutes long so it's
going to be a shorter episode this is
not uh going to be the standard going
forward I still want to keep them to
about 15 or 16 minutes uh roughly
somewhere around there uh but yeah so
unfortunately I'm going to have to end
it here but let's go have a quick recap
of what we did this episode um because
we did make quite a bit of gain so on um
the combat skills we didn't make
anything um the magic levels we got to
55 which is nice we can now use high
Alchemy uh construction I got all the
way till
43 uh do we get any levels I don't think
so but two Fletching levels uh all the
way to 35 smithing just by using the
super heat spell and uh we got some fire
making levels we got all the way to 60
fir making as well as uh one wood
cutting level and uh a bunch of farming
levels so we're all the way to 30
farming now we can actually plant the uh
Willow seed without having to use the
garden pie which is kind of nice boom
and in the ground and uh yeah so that
brings our total level to
737 so only 13 more total levels which
we can easily reach only going to take
another couple hours but unfortunately
like I said we just have some actual in
real life stuff to have to go deal with
and yes so let's go ahead and quickly
have a look at our grand exchange and
we'll finish this up okay so for the
grand exchange I have quite a few offers
waiting to sell I surprisingly got 50 of
these toy cats and three Old Demon masks
and two uh pickaxe kits so we have about
600k and another 670k so about
1,300 and another 160 that's like uh
1,500 1.5 mil in a grand exchange
roughly plus a little bit more so we're
getting up there I'm excited for the
flips to come in we'll be at about 3 mil
after that and that's including
investing a lot of money into our skills
so thanks a lot for everyone who tuned
into episode 9 appreciate the ongoing
support for this series and I'll see you
guys in episode number 10
[Music]